now Jimmy wasn't on hand yesterday when
they rolled out the Oskar red carpet but
later we got a chance to sit down and
talk about getting back on that Oscar
hosting horse after last year's Best
Picture debacle personally I blame Steve
Harvey for this last year you said you'd
never come back you were done that was
it
when did you catch me when did I say
that
well Jimmy you said it right after that
massive wrong envelope fail is there any
PTSD no no no in fact it went great
except for the thing at the end with you
know turn out to be a something that was
interesting to people you know and I
guess the the worst thing the Oscars can
be is boring I think right this there's
a mistake moonlight you guys won Best
Picture all hell broke loose and I think
that it wasn't great then but now this
year for some reason it has increased
the interest in the show and when he
takes the stage Sunday night on ABC
Jimmy says expect a lot of talk about
current headlines it seems like every
year there are serious things happening
this year it seems like there are nine
of them all happening at once so that's
something that I think has to be handled
has to be balanced about two months
after last year's Oscars Little Billy
Kimmel was born with a congenital heart
condition this is Billy I was out last
week because this guy had a heart
surgery but look he's fine everybody how
is your son doing in I think that you
know most of America and the world after
seeing you that night when you talked
about him it changed like how people
felt about you I think it's odd people I
don't know they don't even think of me
as somebody who has kids in the first
place so I to see me care about those
people I guess is I guess is surprising
in a good way
[Music]